- Hi, I am Tiffani Thiessen
and today I'm making my mom's
famous cream cheese pie.
I love this cream cheese pie
one because it has cheese
in it and I'm a cheese lover
and two, because it was
something that my mom always made
and it was something that brought memories
every time I would have a bite.
I remember literally growing
up having this cream cheese pie
at every special occasion and holiday.
I don't remember exactly the first time
I made this pie and it
was quite a long time ago
and I do remember being
very nervous about it
because it's a staple in our family
and I wanted to make sure I did it right.
What's unique about this recipe
is that most people
think it's a cheesecake
but it's actually not.
It's more of a cream cheese pie.
So it has a little more of
the texture of an actual pie.
This cream cheese pie is something
that when I make it for somebody
who hasn't had it before,
they wanna know why I
haven't had it before.
Everybody who makes it,
everybody who has it,
it's something that gets requested
over and over and over again
and I think it's gonna
be the same for you guys.
We usually make the cream
cheese pie for special occasions
and mostly during the holidays
but my daughter does request
it on her birthday as well.
My daughter and I cook a lot together.
She's now seven and a half years old
so she's getting pretty good at it.
She actually has her own set of knives,
kid knives of course but she's
getting really great at it.
She likes to be alongside me
and we are definitely making
memories in the kitchen.
It's a special time right now.
I started cooking as a young little girl
kind of peering my head through the corner
watching the other ladies in
my family cooking together
and I wanted to be with them.
I think for me, being in
the kitchen and cooking,
it's just another expression
of being artistic.
I also love trying new things
and being able to be creative
and try new ingredients
and try new techniques is
something that I love to do
and I love also what food does.
I love that food brings people together.
It's a communal type thing
and whether it's your family,
your friends or whatever,
I really love what food does.
- [Narrator] Oh yes.